*Titelmusik*
Willkommen bei Folge 2 von
"wissenschaftlich geprüft".
MadeMyDay -
die Sprüche, die dir den Tag retten.
Seien es Zitate und Weisheiten,
Liebe und Beziehungen oder Wissen.
Vielleicht erinnert sich jemand
an den Beitrag über die Hummeln,
die nicht fliegen können.
Wisst ihr,
was Nerds wirklich aufregt?
*ruhige Musik*
Nein, MadeMyDay sind nicht
die einzigen ihrer Art,
solche Seiten gibt es viele.
Aber sie sind einer der größten
und auf YouTube auch unterwegs.
Der Hauptkanal
hat über 2,5 Mio. Abonnenten,
die sich für LifeHacks, Fakten,
unnützes Wissen usw. interessieren.
Fakten!
Ich werde mir heute
eins von MadeMyDays Faktenvideos
genauer anschauen.
Und zwar: 6 Fakten über MÄNNER,
die sie NIEMALS zugeben würden.
Ich werde prüfen, welche der Fakten
wissenschaftlich belegbar sind,
welche nicht, werde wissenschaftliche
Approvals verteilen
und am Ende ein Gesamturteil
für das ganze Video geben.
Let's go.
Fangen wir an
mit der Nr. 6 und dem Lügen.
Ein Mann liegt im Durchschnitt
sechsmal am Tag.
Am häufigsten belügen wir Kollegen,
Chef und die Partnerin.
Ok, das ist fast genauso gut wie:
ein Mann denkt alle 7 Sekunden
an Sex oder so.
Wie möchte man so was denn bitte
akkurat wissenschaftlich bestimmen?
Wie möchte man so was messen?
Die häufigsten Männerlügen sind:
"Es geht mir gut."
Und: "Ist schon ok."
Nehmen wir das Ganze doch einfach
mal spaßeshalber superernst.
Spaßeshalber superernst!
Und überlegen uns, wie man das Ganze
prinzipiell messen könnte,
wenn man wollte.
Also sagen wir,
man könnte einen Lügendetektor
im Alltag an Menschen anbringen,
was man nicht kann.
Und dieser Lügendetektor würde Lügen
immer akkurat detektieren.
Was er nicht tut!
Dann könnte man trotzdem Lügen wie:
"Es geht mir gut" und "Ist schon ok."
wohl nicht detektieren,
weil Lügendetektoren körperliche
Anzeichen von Nervosität aufzeichnen.
Wie z.B. erhöhten Puls.
Und ich glaube kaum, dass jemand
nervös wird, wenn er die "Lüge"
"ist schon ok" von sich gibt.
Es gibt keinen wissenschaftlichen
Weg, Lügen aufzudecken.
Wie etwa, keine Ahnung,
ein Hirnscanner,
der Gedanken lesen kann,
so was gibt es auch nicht.
Ich nehme das Ganze zu ernst!
Was ich damit sagen will:
um an Zahlen zu kommen,
wie Männer lügen sechsmal am Tag
oder Frauen lügen dreimal am Tag,
kann man nur auf eine Weise kommen,
nämlich durch Befragungen.
Bei denen die Befragten selbst
angeben, wie oft sie lügen.
Ihr könnt euch selbst überlegen, wie
wissenschaftlich akkurat das ist.
Natürlich sind unter dem MadeMyDay
Video keine Quellen angegeben
für ihre Fakten.
Aber glücklicherweise
ist MadeMyDay bekannt dafür,
sich anderweitig zu inspirieren.
In diesem Fall von BrightSide.
Gibt es auch auf Deutsch:
Sonnenseite.
"15 Fakten über Männer,
die sie nicht gerne zugeben"
Und zufälligerweise sind die 6 Fakten
von MadeMyDay da auch drin.
Hmmm!
Jedenfalls bin ich froh darüber,
denn auf der englischen Homepage
von BrightSide
gibt es einen entsprechenden Artikel
mit 11 Akten.
Über Männer,
und da sind die 6 auch mit drin.
Und hierzu gibt es wenigstens
jeweils ein paar Sätze
und jeweils eine Verlinkung
zu der Quelle.
Ist schon mal was!
Jetzt setzt euch hin,
Freunde der Sonne,
die Quelle für diesen Fakt
ist eine Umfrage,
von 20th Century Fox.
*Jingle*
Einem der Major Filmstudios.
Die haben diese Umfrage durchgeführt
im Rahmen einer PR-,
einer Marketingkampagne,
für die Fernsehserie "Lie to me".
Mal abgesehen davon,
dass 20th Century Fox
kein wissenschaftliches Institut ist,
muss man eigentlich nur einen Blick
auf die Top10-Lies der Männer werfen,
die... äh...
Die sind einfach nur
wie aus einer Männer-Karikatur
von Mario Barth entsprungen.
Nr.2 von den Top-10-Lügen ist:
"Das ist mein letztes Bier."
Männer, immer right,
immer am Saufen und Lügen.
Das wissen wir doch alle.
Lange Rede, kurzer Sinn,
Fakt Nr. 1, bzw. Nr. 6...
Bei MadeMyDay
haben wir immer einen Countdown.
...not approved! Fakt Nr. 5:
Laut einer Studie der Universität
Granada bevorzugen die meisten Männer
schlanke Frauen, die aber dennoch
nicht abgemagert aussehen,
sondern ein gesundes Gewicht haben.
Hier ist auf einen Artikel verlinkt,
über die Forschung
einer spanischen Wissenschaftlerin
von der Universität Granada.
Ich hab mal geschaut,
was sie sonst so macht.
Sie beschäftigt sich v.a.
mit Dingen wie
Body Image,
Selbstwahrnehmung und Essstörungen
in ihrer psychologischen Forschung.
Dieser Artikel ist nicht besonders
gut ins Englische übersetzt.
Zumindest der Titel
müsste eigentlich eher heißen:
"Men like female thin bodies more
than women do." Oder so.
Hier geht es leider nicht um das,
was im Video gesagt wurde,
sondern vielmehr ums Gegenteil.
Nämlich, dass Männern die Schlankheit
von Frauen wichtiger ist,
als es den Frauen wichtig ist.
Hier wird zwar am Ende erwähnt,
dass Männer in Spanien durchaus
auf ein "gesundes" Gewicht
bei Models stehen.
Also schon schlank, aber gesund.
Nicht zu dünn.
Allerdings ist das offensichtlich
nicht der Fokus ihrer Forschung.
Auch nicht das, was sie gefunden hat.
Sondern genau im Gegenteil:
dass Männer
lieber schlanke Frauen mögen.
Deswegen leider Fakt Nr. 5:
not approved.
Es gibt aber noch einen zweiten Teil
von Fakt Nr. 5.
Außerdem schreckt es viele Männer ab,
wenn eine Frau beim ersten Date
hustet oder erkältet ist.
Typisch Mann, oder?
Wer zum Teufel
wird denn gerne an gehustet?
Übrigens ist die Abneigung
gegen Husten und Niesen
und andere Zerstäubungen von
Körperflüssigkeiten ganz natürlich,
weil wir uns auch vor potentiellen
Krankheitserregern schützen möchten,
indem wir sie vermeiden.
Ich denke auch nicht, dass es jemals
eine wissenschaftliche Studie
zu Gender-Unterschieden in der
Wahrnehmung von Husten geben wird.
Hab ich Sie richtig verstanden?
Sie möchten untersuchen,
ob Männer es unschön finden,
von Frauen angehustet zu werden?
Ja, genau.
- Und was ist Ihre Hypothese?
Außer: "No shit, Sherlock"?
Und für diese Forschung
möchten Sie Steuergelder haben?
Also Fakt Nr. 5b: approved.
Weil Menschen
nicht gerne angehustet werden
und Männer auch Menschen sind.
Gut, Fakt Nr. 4:
Nr. 4: Daumen und Gürtel.
Männer stecken unterbewusst
die Daumen in den Gürtel
oder die Hosentaschen,
um Mädels zu beeindrucken.
Dieses Verhalten
lässt sich interessanterweise
auch bei Affenarten beobachten.
Diese zeigen, um ein Weibchen
auf sich aufmerksam zu machen,
auf ihren Schritt.
Da merkt man mal wieder,
dass wir vom Affen abstammen.
Ok, erstens,
wir stammen nicht vom Affen ab.
Wir haben evolutionstechnisch gesehen
dieselben Vorfahren.
Und warum... Och!
...muss ich jetzt diesen Affen... ?
Mimik und Körpersprache
werden wissenschaftlich
tatsächlich schon lange untersucht.
Körpersprache hat wissenschaftlich
gesehen also durchaus
Hand und Fuß.
*Tusch*
Aber vieles
ist auch einfach nur empirisch.
Gehen wir mal auf Quellensuche.
Wieder über die BrightSide-Seite
wurde auf diesen Artikel verlinkt:
Kein wissenschaftlicher Artikel,
aber es sind zwei Quellen angegeben.
Eine Quelle davon ist dieses Paper,
das sich mit der Wahrnehmung
eines ausgestreckten Mittelfingers
beschäftigt.
Sehr interessant, hat nur nichts
mit der Gürtelpose zu tun.
Und zweitens ist ein Buch verlinkt.
Dabei handelt es sich um "The
Definitive Book of Body Language"
von Allan und Barbara Pease.
Allan und Barbara Pease sind
ein Ehepaar, Bestsellerautoren.
Bekannt von Bestsellern wie:
Sie standen immer wieder
in die Kritik,
dass sie Nichtwissenschaftliches
als Fakten verkaufen.
Die beiden sind auch keineswegs
Psychologen oder Wissenschaftler.
Ich denke, wir können uns
sicher darauf einigen,
dass diese "typische" Cowboypose
in unserem Kulturkreis
etwas typisch Männliches ist.
Und dass das auch eine Art
von Imponiergehabe sein kann.
Und dass es durchaus den Fokus
auf den Genitalbereich lenkt.
Aber ob das jetzt
etwas Urbiologisches ist,
was die Affen auch machen,
oder ob das einfach kulturell,
gesellschaftlich verankert ist,
müsste untersucht werden.
Ich will jetzt nicht sagen,
dass das Ganze nicht stimmt.
Aber darum geht es hier
auch gar nicht,
sondern darum, ob etwas
wissenschaftlich belegt ist.
Hier muss ich sagen...
more research needed.
Fakt Nr.3...
*es klingelt*
Moment.
Hey.
- Was machst du hier?
Du bist zu früh.
Wir machen das erst in der End Card.
Aber das wichtige Announcement?
Ich weiß,
aber ich bin noch nicht fertig.
Ich komm gleich noch mal.
Okay, sorry.
Auch wenn es fast kein Mann
zugeben würde,
wir Männer bekommen gern Komplimente
von anderen Männern.
Laut Robert Herbert von der
Binghamton Universität in New York
steigern diese Komplimente nämlich
enorm unser Selbstbewusstsein.
Herbert hat untersucht,
wie gut wir Komplimente annehmen.
Denn wie ihr selbst wisst,
ist es nicht immer ganz einfach,
Komplimente anzunehmen.
Sagen wir, ich bekomme
ein Kompliment: "Cooles T-Shirt!"
Da gibt es grob zwei Möglichkeiten,
damit umzugehen.
Entweder annehmend oder ablehnend.
Annehmend kann sein, sich
einfach zu bedanken: "Dankeschön."
Sich bedanken
und noch was dazu sagen:
"Danke, das ist eins
meiner Lieblingsshirts.
Das ist ein Broktus, eine Mischung
aus Kaktus und Brokkoli."
Man kann auch danken
und das Kompliment zurückgeben:
"Danke, deins auch."
Oder man kann ablehnend reagieren.
D.h. nicht unbedingt,
dass man das Kompliment nicht mag,
aber dass man so reagiert,
indem man es relativiert:
"Das? Ach, ist schon ok.
Ich mein,
was soll das überhaupt sein?
Brokkoli oder Kaktus?"
Indem man es komplett zurückweist:
"Das? Quatsch, das ist doch albern."
Oder indem man gar nicht reagiert
und sich einfach nur unwohl fühlt.
Robert Herbert hat sich angeschaut,
wie Frauen und Männer
verschieden mit Komplimenten umgehen.
Wie sie darauf reagieren,
wenn die Komplimente
von Frauen oder Männern kommen.
Und dabei hat er
interessanterweise festgestellt,
dass Komplimente,
die von Männern kommen,
am ehesten akzeptiert werden,
also angenommen werden.
Besonders auffällig
war der Unterschied bei Frauen,
die Komplimente bekamen.
Wenn sie Komplimente
von anderen Frauen bekamen,
reagierten sie eher ablehnend.
"Was? Quatsch!"
Wenn sie Komplimente von Männern
bekamen, nahmen sie die eher an.
"Danke."
Bei Männern war der Unterschied
nicht ganz so groß, aber trotzdem da.
Komplimente von anderen Männern
konnten sie eher akzeptieren,
Komplimente von Frauen
wurden eher abgelehnt.
Die Ergebnisse dieser Studie
beinhalten zwar,
das Männer Komplimente von anderen
Männern leichter annehmen.
Das sagt aber nichts darüber aus,
ob sie diese Komplimente lieber hören
oder ob sie
ihr Selbstbewusstsein stärken.
Interessante Studie,
nur leider in diesem Video
Interpretation leicht verfehlt.
Deswegen leider: not approved.
Fakt Nr. 2:
Während Frauen
nach Freundinnen suchen,
die emotional mit ihnen
auf einer Ebene stehen,
suchen Männer nach Freunden,
die die gleichen Interessen haben
wie sie selbst.
Damit sind Männerfreundschaften
zwar oberflächlicher,
aber dafür auch wesentlich
entspannter als Frauenfreundschaften.
Es gibt durchaus
wissenschaftliche Studien dazu.
Wobei die meisten davon
relativ alt sind.
Aber da wurde festgestellt,
dass Männerfreundschaften
tatsächlich oberflächlicher sind.
Zumindest kann man es
so interpretieren.
Weil Männer z.B. selbst angeben,
dass sie mehr Freunde haben,
als Frauen es selber angeben.
Während Frauen mehr Zeit mit ihrer
Freundschaftspflege verbringen,
d.h. sie telefonieren öfter,
treffen sich öfter.
Zumindest
mit den engsten Freundinnen.
Wenn man sich alte Studien anschaut,
werden Männerfreundschaften immer
beschrieben als die großen Rudel.
Männer in größeren,
oberflächlichen Freundesgruppen.
Frauen
in intimen Zweierfreundschaften
mit der besten Freundin.
Das hatte was damit zu tun,
dass früher nur die Männer
zur Arbeit gegangen sind
und da z.B. Arbeitskollegen hatten.
Während die Hausfrau die eine beste
Freundin aus der Nachbarschaft hatte.
Das ist heute natürlich
auch nicht mehr so.
Aber wenn man jetzt mal all diese
Betrachtungsweisen mit einbezieht,
ist das,
was in dem Video gesagt wird,
durchaus wissenschaftlich belegt.
Darum geht es hier wie gesagt auch.
Deswegen ein "Approved".
Fakt Nr. 1:
Damit sind wir auch schon bei
der heutigen Nr. 1 und der Kleidung.
Während wir im jungen Alter
noch Skinny Jeans o.ä. tragen,
weil wir das als modisch ansehen,
wechseln die meisten von uns
mit zunehmendem Alter
zu lockerer, bequemerer Kleidung.
Ich weiß nicht, wie ihr das seht,
aber für mich ist dieser Punkt
genauso no-shit-sherlocky
wie der Punkt mit dem Husten.
Ich denke nicht,
dass man Gesellschaftswissenschaftler
oder Psychologe sein muss,
um zu wissen, dass Modetrends
eher von Jüngeren verfolgt werden.
Und dass einem Modetrends
ab irgend'nem Alter eher egal sind.
Vielleicht meinen sie es
nicht wissenschaftlich,
sondern wollen nur einen
offensichtlichen Fakt mit aufnehmen.
Aber mal im Ernst,
vor zehn Jahren und auch heute
trage ich am liebsten
bequemen Pulli und Jogginghose.
Aber wenn das die Statistik sagt,
wird das schon stimmen.
Nope, es soll
eine Statistik dahinterstehen.
MadeMyDay.
Wenn ihr offensichtliche Tatsachen,
die jeder weiß,
noch mal in nem Video
auflisten möchtet, fein.
Aber dann seid wenigstens so gut
und lasst die Statistik raus.
Und tut nicht so,
als hättet ihr Zahlen!
Übrigens ist die Quelle
für diesen Fakt laut BrightSide
eine Diskussion auf Quora.
Fazit:
"Fakten" ist nicht das beste Wort
für diesen Videotitel.
Gesamturteil: not approved.
Natürlich gilt dieses Review
nicht nur MadeMyDay,
sondern auch BrightSide
und Sonnenseite,
die noch mehr als 6 Fakten haben,
die ich nicht geprüft habe.
Außerdem, kann mir irgendjemand
von euch erklären,
welchen Sinn
dieses Thumbnailen ergibt?
Müsste der jüngere Mann
nicht engere Badehosen tragen?
Warum ist dieses Thumbnail so gut,
dass MadeMyDay es übernehmen musste?
Oder gehören die zusammen?
Ich versteh das nicht.
Falls ihr Vorschläge habt,
welches YouTube Video
ich wissenschaftlich prüfen soll,
schreibt es in die Kommentare.
Jetzt wird es wirklich Zeit
für die End Card.
Darf ich jetzt?
- Ja, und beeil dich bitte.
Bevor die Nachbarn gucken.
Hey, maiLab wurde für den
Grimme Online Award nominiert.
Und es gibt einen Publikumspreis.
D.h. wenn ihr
für uns abstimmen möchtet,
könnt ihr das tun unter dem Link
in der Videobeschreibung.
Das war's auch schon. Das hätten wir
auch locker vorhin machen können.
Was hast du?
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von Funk (2018)